hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo lo
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
tras más de un mes de iniciada la guerra
contra ucrania la atención está puesta
sobre las casi 4 millones de personas
que huyen del país en busca de seguridad
pero la guerra también deja al
descubierto la desigualdad en la acogida
de los migrantes y refugiados de otras
nacionalidades que se alejan de
diferentes conflictos la generosa
acogida de los últimos días contrasta
con la dura respuesta de los últimos
años veamos lo que pasa en la frontera
entre méxico y eeuu
una frontera concurrida que recibe a
unos visitantes inusuales un grupo de
ciudadanos rusos espera en el lado
mexicano de la frontera con eeuu
llegaron hasta aquí para pedir asilo
pero no han contado con suerte las
fronteras están abiertas para los
ucranianos pero al parecer cerradas para
los rusos para quienes tampoco es una
opción regresar a su país
es una especie de no sé discriminación
en problema tenemos el mismo problema si
en mi país no hay guerra pero en mi país
hay un régimen y yo estoy escapando de
eso
para mijail por ejemplo alejarse de
rusia era la única opción para no
combatir contra sus parientes en ucrania
mi país es peligroso para mí soy un
hombre joven y mi mamá es originaria de
ucrania y
tengo muchos hermanos y hermanas en
ucrania
así que atacaron a mi país pero si
vuelvo a rusia iré al ejército y tendré
que matar a mis hermanos y hermanas
por esa y otras razones viajaron hasta
tijuana pero ahora no hay claridad sobre
sus pedidos de refugio
una espera en la que han gastado todas
sus reservas y dicen que no tienen de
dónde echar mano en parte por las
sanciones impuestas por occidente a
compañías y bancos rusos
y
estamos en una situación desesperada
en una situación económica
potencialmente terrible porque no
podemos tener ninguna fuente estable de
ingresos de rusia debido a las sanciones
y sanciones a algunos ucranianos que
llegaron hasta tijuana se les otorgó un
permiso temporal para permanecer en eeuu
por un año por lo que organizaciones de
ayuda en la frontera denuncian un trato
desigual
y aquí no se trata de agresores rusos
son disidentes rusos que también
intentan protestar u opinar en contra de
la dictadura de putin
se enfrentan a persecución y torturas y
son retornados a rusia
también tienen miedo de volver por la
misma razón por la misma razón que los
ucranianos están entrando
pero no solo a los rusos se les rechaza
en el ingreso a eeuu solicitantes de
asilo de otros países africanos
centroamericanos y latinoamericanos
tampoco pueden ingresar aunque la gran
mayoría huyen de las críticas
condiciones de vida en sus países
hungría está entre los países vecinos de
ucrania que abre sus puertas a los
refugiados que huyen de la guerra más de
350.000 personas llegaron al país y la
recepción ha sido buena no pasa lo mismo
con quienes no huyen de la invasión rusa
a través de expulsiones ilegales y
violentas las autoridades envían a
migrantes y refugiados fuera del país la
historia a continuación
una suerte que se baraja por la
nacionalidad después de vivir durante
tres años en hungría así fue expulsado y
enviado a la vecina serbia y es que
aunque el país le abrió las puertas a
los refugiados ucranianos que huyen de
la guerra la respuesta no es la misma
para con otros solicitantes de asilo o
la autorización de polientes que sin
ninguna razón la policía vino a esposar
me me dieron dos o tres advertencias
antes de hacerlo me dijeron algo así
como no intente subir no intentes pelear
con nosotros no hagas ninguna tontería
es súper fácil es afgano estudiaba en
hungría y buscaba un mejor futuro lejos
de casa cuenta que la vaga idea de
retornar se desdibujó una vez los
talibanes retomaron el poder en el país
y su familia cercana al anterior
gobierno corre peligro
me sentí horrible y terrible porque era
un estudiante normal estudiaba iba a
clase tenía mis propios amigos tenía mi
propia vida allí
tenía mi propio grupo social con mis
compañeros de clase después de lo que
hicieron mi vida cambió totalmente
bailar twitter y james
una historia similar que cuentan otros
peticionarios de refugio
era julio y todo estaba verde estaba
bastante conmocionado no habíamos
dormido durante tres días no dormimos
nada y nos echaron de allí no tenía ni
idea de dónde estaba ni de lo que estaba
pasando
organizaciones de ayuda denuncian que
hungría envía a los solicitantes de
refugio a terceros países sin tener en
cuenta su necesidad de protección
es idéntico la naturaleza de la
violación es idéntica pero la gravedad
de la violación es mayor cuando se trata
de personas que nunca han estado en
serbia sucedió
but entero en general esta práctica es
aplicada por las autoridades húngaras
independientemente del hecho de si esta
persona estaba en serbia antes de la
expulsión o no no hay diferencia a
resolverse defensa un tribunal húngaro
fallo a favor deja shift pero los
abogados ahora están librando otra
batalla legal para obligar a las
autoridades de hungría que le permitan
regresar
la unión europea' enfocó una directiva
de 2001 para garantizar la acogida e
integración de los refugiados ucranianos
la pregunta es por qué hasta ahora
cuando en 2015 más de un millón de
sirios afganos e iraquíes huyeron en
busca de seguridad hasta que inmigrantes
de france24 los invitamos a comentar en
nuestras redes sociales con el hashtag
migrantes f24 sigan con más información
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]